so a dream is fundamentally how you  imagine yourself  or in the modern parlance it's the  ultimate self-portrait of the ultimate  selfie so all the characters in the  dream are reflections of usually latent  characteristics that you may have but  you have the opportunity to express and  enact in waking life dreams are the  ultimate selfie i like that well um  that's that's incredible and um  i love what you said about storytelling  and i never really thought about that  before you know reza and i talk a lot  about storytelling that's something that  we're obviously very involved in we  believe in the power of storytelling we  do that through you know podcasting we  do that through television we do that  through writing and  but i hadn't really connected dreams as  being kind of the fountain  of storytelling